welcome welcome to the livestream can
never really tell exactly when I'm live
but it seems like it's probably about
now oh I've already been live ten
seconds that means I was probably
staring at the camera like a fool for a
few seconds that's okay thanks for
joining me I've got a bunch of stuff to
talk about might open the phone lines
later and hear from people in the
audience I'm going to be talking about
the shutdown still going on and now we
have we have an unenviable OC of Donald
Trump from the State of the Union which
I already talked about today on the
broadcast show and then now Donald Trump
has tried to cancel Nancy Pelosi's
future trips but she had already
cancelled the trips he's trying to
cancel so it's all very very dumb but
the most important thing is 800,000
people aren't getting paid or are
furloughed and then millions of
contractors who don't work for the
federal government but indirectly work
for the federal government are affected
so it's a it's a mess and we're going to
talk about that I'm also going to talk
about just the total identity politics
fail and I'm going to talk about it not
to give ammunition to the right because
they're already talking about it but to
really try to explain to the left why we
just can't do this stuff I will get to
that we'll also talk about a House vote
362 to 53 against allowing the lifting
of Russian sanctions and of course
that's a lot of Democrats but it's some
Republicans as well and that's that's
good news so before we get into any of
that stuff if this is your first YouTube
livestream and you're used to watching
my recorded videos number one this is
live yes it's really live unless it's a
replay it's 6:30 p.m. Eastern on January
17 2019 if it's not that time right now
then this is a replay I will take
questions from the audience using the
super chat function that's the dollar
sign at the bottom of the chat window if
you want me to read your question or
comment and react to it answer it use
the super chat function new members and
patrons will get live shoutouts during
the lie
stream if you sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership or
patreon.com slash david pakman show well
if we get 10 new members and patrons
during the stream I'll open up the phone
lines and take phone calls from people
and as people know the sooner we do that
the sooner we get to calls the more
calls I can take and I'll talk a little
bit later about why there's been such a
push for membership during January 2019
so far
please don't troll the live chat we do
have moderators in there and I find if I
notice you you're probably doing
something annoying so obvious trolling
and hate will get you banned and you can
also become a youtube sponsor using the
blue join button which should be right
below the video window if things are if
things are going correctly so let's get
right into it and then we'll weave in
and out between some stories and super
chats as we get new members and patrons
if we do we will give them shout outs
and open up the phone lines and as if
you if you've been recently watching
other streamers including dave rubin you
would know that literally anything goes
during during super chat any question or
a comment can pop up and I know a lot of
you know know exactly what I'm talking
about and and they're not always
necessarily questions or comments that
the streamer may want to read or or may
want to call attention to so let's get
first to let's see if I can pull up some
of this stuff for everybody okay let's
get first to so let's set this first
story up and then obviously at any point
my browser audio could go down and then
we won't be able to hear any of the
stuff I have planned to play play for
you but let's hope that doesn't happen
Nancy Pelosi has uninvited Donald Trump
from giving his State of the Union
address at the House of Representatives
on January 29th I believe it is it's
sort of a formality that the Speaker of
the House invites the president to give
the State of the Union address but it's
sort of not because it is by invitation
only and she has rescinded that
invitation to push back against that
Donald Trump now is trying to cancel a
trip that Nancy Pelosi already had
canceled let's take a listen to this
report about it hopefully this will this
will work let's see
of how petty and small the president can
be by the way on Tuesday the speaker has
already made it clear that all members
are going to be in Washington so it's
not business as usual for us we are
going to be here legislating we
initially had a district work period
typically that is when congressional
delegation trips to foreign locations
are scheduled but in this case the
speaker already made it clear all bets
are off business as usual is suspended
and we're going to stay here continuing
to do our work until we get a resolution
or do you say this trip wasn't even on
the table before the shutdown ended I I
don't know really anything about the
trip specifically but the president's
reference to the fact that we're not
here and we shouldn't be anywhere but in
Washington the speaker has already made
it clear that that's her intention that
we cancel how can we I think you get the
gist of it this was um this was hours
ago and indeed Nancy Pelosi wasn't even
wasn't even going on this trip so this
entire you know the most disappointing
thing for me about the entire shutdown
is that the the real people that are
being affected are becoming secondary or
even tertiary here I mean you've got
800,000 federal employees and millions
of contractors who aren't getting paid
or are furloughed or are impacted in one
way or another TSA is not getting paid
that is literally to the extent that you
believe TSA makes our airports safer and
I think that that is marginally true not
having TSA paid and having call-outs and
all of this other nonsense going on
it makes our aviation less safe so this
is the that's the real disaster and as
far as blame it's very popular to talk
about in some cases it's a we're not
looking to place blame we're looking to
solve the problem type of thing in other
cases it's know that the blame actually
matters blame actually matters here okay
and there's really nothing that we have
to look hard for under rocks or in any
obscure places for for blame days before
the shutdown Trump said he would shut
down the government if he feels he needs
to if he doesn't get bored or while
funding and that he would be proud to do
it and then he shut it down that's it I
mean any anything else ancillary about
yes Mitch McConnell could accelerate
opening government if you brought some
of these bills to it to the Senate for a
vote
sure
yeah Democrats could get government
reopened if they just gave Trump
whatever the hell he wanted but Trump
shut it down
he's making demands that make no sense
and that's the one person who's who's
responsible here period okay let me get
to that one Super chat that came in
before I go on to my next story that
first one is from Trevor Peterson for
five bucks who says in the unlikely
event that Trump and pence are removed
from office and Nancy Pelosi becomes
president would she run in 2020 or let
someone else run not gonna touch it
Trevor because this is as you're
pointing out this is so out there that
that's such an out-there scenario let's
take it day-by-day we've got an
investigation going on right now we're
quickly learning that the charitable
business and personal lives and campaign
lives of Donald Trump all seem to have
contained criminality over the last many
years and we will we will see what
ultimately happens the progressive voice
is in the actual in the Super chats who
is your favorite Dragon Ball Z character
I've never seen an episode don't even
know what that is are you going to watch
the bro Lee movie I don't know what that
is either do I think the New England
Patriots will go to the Superbowl
absolutely and what's my favorite biggie
song going back to Cali I I'm doing my
best to answer answer all of your
questions okay let's get next to what I
am calling a total identity politics
fail okay
now I want this relates to David Webb
who is a a black tea party guy who has a
Sirius XM radio show I want a circumvent
and short-circuit the criticism that
some will give me which is David you
shouldn't even mention this story
because it gives the right-wing fuel the
right already has fuel and we're gonna
keep giving them more fuel unless people
on the Left stop this nonsense so I'm
gonna play for you what took place today
on David Webb's program there's a CNN
legal analyst named Arriva Martin she
was being interviewed by David Webb and
she thought David Webb was white okay
and as a result of that she identified
that he was exercising his white
privilege or that a perspective of his
was influenced by white privilege the
problem is he's not white okay and this
why this is such a toxic thing that some
people and it's not a huge portion but
when it happens they get a lot of
attention and that's why it's so toxic
this is something that we have to root
out and I'll talk more about it in a
second okay let's listen to what went
down today and it's really bad it's
horrible take a listen
parts of the media world done the work
so that I'm qualified to be in each one
I never considered my color the issue I
considered my qualifications the issue
well David you know that that's a whole
nother long conversation about white
privilege the things that you have the
privilege of doing that people of color
don't have the privilege of how do I
have the gray village of David by virtue
of being a white male you have white
privilege I hate to break it to you but
you should have been better prepped I'm
black you went to white privilege this
is the fall suit in this you went
immediately with an assumption your
people obviously or you didn't look
you're talking to a black man who
started out in rock radio in Boston you
get it okay I think you get it at this
point here's the thing white privilege
is real period in the United States
which is a predominantly white country
with with significant historical
advantages for white people you could
talk about other countries and the
situation may be different the United
States white privilege is a real thing
but it's not a winning argument to tell
someone that they are wrong because they
have white privilege number one it's not
really a broader argument about how
society functions and whether a policy
is good or bad in that sense it's a
losers battle to start talking about
you're you're wrong because you have
white privilege number two you can get
the identity wrong okay and this has
happened on this program where people
misidentify me not knowing English is my
second language I'm an immigrant from
Argentina
my family came here with no money and
all this different stuff and and yes
there's no question that because I am
perceived as just an american-born
white person I certainly have benefited
from that in society once we got to a
certain point right of education and and
other things but it's just it's a
loser's game and this is exactly I mean
this is a faceplant of the kind that you
you literally cannot recover from this
because you're not making an argument
right you've lost before you even
actually get into talking about anything
serious because you've just miss
identified someone and said you have
white privilege it's a black guy okay
the other issue about the the other
problem with this type of stuff is that
I've identified the problems with
playing identity politics games by the
left but I've also pointed out identity
is relevant okay one's identity is the
the number one determining factor as to
how the rest of the world perceives you
okay it immediately when someone meets
you they are instantly assessable what
is this person's gender what is this
person's age what is this person's race
I mean immediately the at the
subconscious level it doesn't mean
you're necessarily being prejudicial on
that basis although many of us have
implicit biases so to pretend that
identity doesn't matter is is is wrong
and I don't do that
okay but the problem becomes when we
start playing this type of identity
politics and when this happens the real
way in which identity matters no longer
makes a difference because you've
already lost the thread you've lost the
argument and you're opening yourself up
to criticism so this was just so
disappointing to see don't fall into
these traps don't make identity based
arguments if the conversation is whether
white privilege exists you don't need to
accuse any particular person of having
white privilege in order to have that
conversation in a full and serious
manner and and point out that white
privilege does exist the pointing out of
individuals as having or not having
white privilege it's not a way to win
and it's just it's not anything it's
nothing it's completely vapid and and I
would encourage people to completely
stay away from it okay let me get before
we get to our next story let me get to a
couple of super chats
and let me do a couple new patron and
member announcements Russell Higgins is
a brand new patron at patreon.com slash
David Pakman show Russell thank you
that's one of ten okay if we get ten new
members and patrons during the
livestream
I'll open up the phone lines and take
calls from people this is we've got to
coupon codes that are available right
now okay if you go to www.petland.com
slash membership you can pick any
membership so for example you could take
the $12 a month membership and hit the
signup button and then you can use the
coupon code this is 20 20 that'll drop
any membership 40% okay so the $12 a
month membership would drop to seven
dollars and 20 cents a month if you do a
six dollar membership and apply that
this is twenty twenty coupon code it'll
drop it to three dollars and sixty cents
a month and that that matters okay so I
don't know what other shows have going
on in terms of giving levels or whatever
but three dollars and sixty cents if
enough people do it does move the needle
so please don't think that that doesn't
make a difference for what what we're
doing and for independent media if you
want to take advantage of a limited time
special with which more than 350 people
have already signed up in the month of
January you can switch over to the
yearly tab and make sure you leave the
sixty dollar a year membership selected
and hit the sign up button if you enter
the coupon code 2019 on this particular
membership sixty dollars a year it'll
drop it to $20.19 that's our limited
time twenty twenty nineteen special
which I teased for weeks at the end of
December and more than three hundred and
fifty people just in January have taken
advantage of it and we could were
potentially on track to have the biggest
new member month ever dating all the way
back even to that month of what we call
ad pocalypse where we lost ninety nine
percent of our YouTube revenue so please
if you want me to open up the phone
lines and take some calls take advantage
of that you will get a thank you from me
Russell Higgins already signed up on
patreon either counts we're just looking
to get to ten and then I'll take phone
calls okay let's get to a couple of
other
super chats here Adam the D with a $10
super chat the biggest super chat of the
evening asks with the Overton Window so
far to the right would it benefit the
left to have some legit or even feigned
Communist making arguments in bad faith
simply to pull the window closer to our
position I've talked about this before
and that's how I mean you people might
hear that and think what what on earth
is Adam talking about but that's
actually something I've discussed before
which is that there you don't see we
have seen what is called asymmetrical
radicalization Google that there's a
number of really good articles about it
which is that if you imagine if we take
let's take the real position on abortion
which is that abortion is legal
we have roe v wade but there are
restrictions about on abortions and
where they can happen and when they can
happen in that type of thing you have an
asymmetrically radicalized spectrum of
debate around that issue where on the
right you have people who say any
abortion is murder birth control is
murder you have some extremists who
actually say every abortion should be
illegal abortion doctors should go to
prison it's a very extreme right-wing
position you don't have the opposite of
that on the left you had you don't have
people on the Left who say abortions up
to and including when the kid is not as
old should be legal you shouldn't even
need a license to perform an abort you
just don't have that so what happens is
you take the actual position which is
here and then you have all sorts of
crazy positions to the right and then
you have positions to the left which are
like well no let's let's just make sure
that we keep abortions legal let's make
sure that abortions are happening in a
safe way in a lot of places so that
people don't have to drive hours to get
there so the middle of that debate ends
up getting pulled to the right so what
Adam that the D is proposing is
something that I've talked about before
and you have to balance it there's
they're sort of two answers answer one
is yes the Overton Window would get
pulled to the left by having more
extreme leftist positions it could
backfire because the right is just much
better at ridiculing
and exposing those absurd left-wing
positions and making them appear
representative of the left in general so
I would agree with you that it would be
great to pull the Overton Window to the
left with the exception that if we're
gonna get extra punished for it by the
right which they're very good at doing
we're gonna lose in the end
nick que no 11 sends a five australian
dollar super chat is there anyone on the
center-right you find value in listening
to no I I mean yeah there's people maybe
but I'm I'm just not really in the
business of promoting right-wing
commenters so I don't really find it
necessary to start naming anybody Terry
James has sent a five-dollar super chat
asking is it ideal for the demographics
of Congress to reflect that of the
general population yeah I think so this
is again talking about asymmetrical
radicalization this is an issue that
comes up as I as I drop my Sharpie when
we talk about what what is diversity
what is equality and what is
representation does it make sense that
because 51 percent 50 and a half percent
of the country is women that we should
have 50 and a half percent of our
elected officials be women I wouldn't go
that far
because you might have reasons that are
complex and reasonable why women are
opting not to run for some of those
positions you have to balance that with
the fact that historically women have
been weren't even considered as valid
lawmakers for a long time and structural
inequalities and all of that stuff so my
position is women are 50 and a half
percent of the population would it be
logical that they make up 5% of the
Senate or the House of Representatives
no does it need to be 50 and a half
percent for us to say that there's
reasonable diversity of gender no it
doesn't have to be 50 and a half percent
what is the exact number I don't know
okay but these are conceptual frameworks
that were applying likewise if 99% of
the House of Representatives is white
when white people are only 70 percent I
forget the exact or 70 something percent
of the population that's wrong if white
people are slightly over or under
represented in Congress is that
necessarily a problem no I don't think
so I think we just have to have sort of
balanced expectations but as a general
rule Terry we do want our elected
officials to broadly speaking represent
the general population when it comes to
a number of factors now with age it's a
different thing because there's a lot of
kids out in the world that doesn't mean
that we want kids in the House of
Representatives so you always have to
make sure you're not making sort of
umbrella statements that that don't make
sense when you carry them to their full
conclusion
Carter Daniels has sent the $10 super
chat what is your favorite Nicktoons
cartoon that aired on Nickelodeon my
favorite is the mighty be you know I
don't even remember which Nickelodeon
which cartoons are Nickelodeon cartoons
I'm trying to think there was one with
Doug remember Doug and Skeeter I think
that that was on Nickelodeon and that's
one that I watched when I was a kid what
what are other Nickelodeon cartoons I
don't even remember I'm not not good
with this stuff but the one with Doug
was cool I remember watching that
behold the GDL with a $2.00 super chap
says the Jews did 9/11 and Mossad
planned it for decades
all right that's that's fine that user
has been banned but we're keeping the
two bucks talk about talk about ironic
there's a 20 dollar super chat that came
in which was a message that was
retracted but I I don't know if we keep
the 20 dollar CERN hot Jesse Stevenson
with the $20 super Chad hola dahveed
nunca couch alone espanol I'm in favor
ideally one panel me gusta mucho let's
enter container all right well there you
go Jesse we we did it Joe Raider with a
five dollar super chat hey did you look
into Ultima Thule more and more data
coming in from New Horizons no I have
not and to be honest Joe I forgot about
what that was
I remember that I mentioned I would look
into that and I think it's like a
nuclear is it a nuclear energy related
thing I'm not sure I even remember now
what it is okay before I get to our
third story of the evening I'll remind
you that we are leaving it up to the
audience as to whether I will open up
the phone lines and take calls if we get
10 new supporters through patreon and
membership tonight I will open up the
phone lines we already had one a patreon
supporter drew Reagan or Regan has
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership using the explosively
popular coupon code 2019 and Robert Lee
not robert e lee just Robert Lee is also
a new david pakman show member that gets
us three out of ten okay so if we get
just one percent of the current live
stream audience to get a membership or
or make a patreon pledge we will be in
business for taking live calls and I saw
a couple comments about this in the chat
yes if we get to live calls early enough
I will consider taking some chess
challenges from the audience at at
lishus and I see a few people saying
that the stream has actually frozen
looks like it's okay to me looks like
it's uh looks like it's fine to me
let me just ban a couple of other people
before we continue because there are the
anti semitism today is just like big Lee
big Lee huge in the live chat one two
let's see here we've got dua ban someone
for saying black people are the real
Jews that's not that's not the normal
anti-semitism that we see but there's a
couple other people I just want to ban
here before we move on okay let me get
to the next story sorry for the
disruption folks let me get to the next
story I wanted to talk about the hill is
reporting amidst a page that is just
filled with ads ads everywhere and I
have a couple more pop up in a major
rebuke of President Trump the House
overwhelmingly the house overwhelming
past this article is a mess but it
communicates what I'm trying to tell you
the house is overwhelming
passed a resolution formerly
disapproving of the Trump
administration's rollback of sanctions
and companies owned by Oleg Deripaska
and Ally of Russian President Vladimir
Putin in the south in a 362 to 53 vote
the house sounded its disapproval of the
lifting of sanctions with 130
Republicans breaking with Trump and
backing the Democratic measure the vote
comes after legislation to prevent the
rolling back of sanctions failed
Wednesday on a procedural vote in the
Senate eleven Republicans voted in the
Senate to prevent the lifting of
sanctions this is a big deal only in
that it's funny they've issued a
correction that they misstated the tally
earlier but they've not corrected a
bunch of the other just grammatical
errors in the article this is a sign
that it is possible that at some point
the criminality of the Trump
administration this is not about
criminality specifically to be clear
it's possible that the criminality of
the Trump administration will at some
point become so egregious and so
undeniable that even Republicans will
decide that yes Donald Trump has to be
held accountable that's why I like the
results here because it shows that
Republicans can break with the president
even on issues of moderate moderate
importance and does this mean that
Republicans would support impeachment of
the president if it came to that no it
doesn't mean that they would but it at
least suggests that there's that
possibility let me get to a couple of
other super chats here let's see a lot
going on Shawn Quintero has sent a $5
Super chat do you hate all metal music
or just the vast majority if not what is
a song you like man so let's see um I
don't know if this counts is metal but I
used to be pretty big into the band
Dream Theater I think it's progressive
rock let me take a sip here and really
the reason I like Dream Theater was
because they had this great drummer Mike
Portnoy but I think he left the band
years ago and it might not even really
be metal I kind of I'm sort of into
Metallica although I guess they're kind
of concern
to pop to be metal what other what can I
say there's some good Ozzy Osbourne's
song I mean I just don't know anything
about any new metal and I couldn't
really even comment on it but no I don't
hate all metal music Zelda freak 22 is
sent to $10 super chat what are the
chances regardless of how the government
shutdown ends if it does Trump using of
if it does of Trump using another
shutdown in September from what the
submitted bills from Congress are
pushing doing a shutdown again ok I'm
not I think there may be like a Google
translation issue there but I think the
question is how likely is it Trump will
use a shutdown again it's likely I mean
it's I think I think that there's no
doubt that it's it's a real possibility
and whether it's so some of the funding
bills the reason September's being
mentioned I think is that some of the
funding bills would fund a bunch of
governments through the end of September
and then we could have the exact same
scenario I think that if Donald Trump is
in trouble
increasingly in in possible legal
trouble that it's even more likely that
he will do it
omma Gaya one has sent a ten Canadian
dollar super chat thank you just wanted
to say I find your show the fairest of
all the progressive channels i watch the
fairest of them all thank you appreciate
that
Joe Raider says oh right that by lobed
30 mile long object out past Pluto in
the is it Kuiper belt
I believe it's how it's pronounced that
is what ultimately is and I have I've
not looked into it but I'm going to try
to today Joe I appreciate that
David Moss thoughts on Sargon getting
banned from patreon I'm barely even
aware so there's a there's a gentleman
who does videos he's a British gelatin
gentleman as far as as far as I know as
far as his accent indicates um and he
his name is Carl Benjamin and I don't
know why that's funny I just find it
funny tick to clarify stating people's
names is not usually funny but there's
something funny about it I'm cracking
myself up he's known on the internet a
sargon of akkad I didn't I'm not I guess
I heard he was banned from patreon and
from what I know there are people who
there are other people who use patreon
who are protesting Sargon being banned
for he said he it was either something
anti-semitic or anti-black maybe he
the n-word I don't remember now people
are protesting patreon by canceling
their patreon accounts and I'm I'm not
doing that
I'm not doing that I have no interest in
doing that and I'm just I'm I'm bored
with race and IQ I'm bored with with
Carl I'm bored with most of the stuff
Jordan Peters doing I'm just bored by it
I don't know how else to say it let me
say thank you to Susan Paris or Paris
Paris harrah's sure how to pronounce the
last name who has become a member at
david pakman.com slash membership we are
six new members or patrons away from me
opening up the phone lines now I'll just
mention we're about a half hour into
this stream I don't have unlimited time
because I am it's my turn to make dinner
tonight as the kids say these days and I
would love to take calls but let's we
should probably let's get those six
other members or patrons in soon the
phone lines are almost ready to go at
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty so there's gonna be no
shortage of phone line capacity if we
indeed get to those ten new members save
40% with the coupon code this is twenty
twenty why not write V has sent a two
dollar super chat David should companies
like Purdue be shut down do you do you
mean Purdue the chicken company why
would they be shut down is it for
farming practices I need a little more
context but I'm not sure offhand of why
Purdue would necessarily be shut down
but if you send me more information I
can address Terry James with a two
dollar super shot should the wall be
opposed for environmental risks among
many others yeah I did a story yesterday
which is up on our YouTube channel
called something like engineers looked
at the wall and it's a disaster and one
of the pieces that's missing from the so
called
proposals for the wall is an
environmental impact assessment and the
impact of the wall would be huge
flooding is one element that we've been
talking about
been talking about more generally the
environmental impact of the wall in some
of the areas where it will need to be
built in order to do what it is that
Donald Trump says so the wall should be
opposed for a whole bunch of reasons not
the least of which that it's gonna cost
50 billion or more even 5 billion I mean
it's just a joke but yeah the
environmental reasons to oppose that are
also prominent phrenic thirty-two
recognized the user name I think phrenic
32 sent a super chat on my last my last
livestream
ban that MF or all these Hebrew
Israelite cultists get on my nerves they
come up to me and expect me to like them
simply because I'm black I don't do you
live in New York City phrenic because
that's the only place I've seen the
so-called black Israelites proselytizing
let me just take a look I'm seeing that
there are a bunch of people getting
banned here
Swedes did 9/11 I don't know if that's
worthy of a ban David is a neoliberal
shill that's definitely not worthy of a
ban
that's that's totally fine for you to uh
for you to say that don't really not
really bothered by that is this a gay
phone line not not really bothered by
that that's just silly
David is an expert on boring nobody's
forcing you to be here Lisa and in fact
that I'd be glad to help you find
another channel that that might be
better for you not sure how you ended up
here if I'm so boring let's get back to
the Super chats actually first love he's
just do let me thank one other person
Daymond Bigler Daymond Bigler has also
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership so we've got five new members
and patrons during the stream if we get
five more and get to ten I'll open up
the phone lines otherwise I won't I've
learned that I need to stick to whatever
goal we set because otherwise what's the
incentive I've got to be credible biz
Wiz has sent a four dollar ninety nine
cent super chat top twenty twenty issues
should be number one campaign finance
reform I agree
number two true universal health care I
agree number three global climate change
number one affects everything
I agree so I've laid out that I believe
that the meta issues the major issues
that have to be part of any serious
platform for 2020 or any time in the
future are campaign finance reform and
how politics is financed universal
healthcare climate change because if
your city floods and it's underwater
it's going to be hard to do anything
else it'll be hard to provide healthcare
it'll be hard to fix our electoral
system etc and net neutrality and media
consolidation is another one of these
pillars because we learn about what's
going on in the world through media and
increasingly through the internet so if
you care about education for example
like if education is your issue we've
got a fixed campaign finance reform so
that we can actually get lobbying money
to stop being so influential in
education we need universal health care
because if people are sick it's really
hard for them to be activists they're
sick and they can't afford treatment
hard for them to be activists for
education global climate change because
if we go underwater education is gonna
fall very far behind and of course media
consolidation and net neutrality because
we're mostly learning about what's going
on in education through the internet and
through media so completely agree mr.
[ __ ] zero for 86 with a 10 dollar
super chat Thank You Nick Kano 11 good
books on israel-palestine that's a whole
can of worms Nick and if you if you
email me I'll send you some suggestions
Fran ferny throw freh with a $10 super
chat bro I too agree in your ultra
fairness and I had to give you $10 for
the Dream Theater shout out thanks for
being a true progressive and for being
as impartial as possible yes progressive
politics and progressive rock if indeed
Dream Theater was was progressive rock
and not metal let me say thank you to
Eric Heaney Haney for being a new member
at david pakman.com slash membership and
i will say hi to adam d who is a new $5
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show that is 7 7 out of 10 if we get to
10 new supporters today
we'll open up the lot the live phone
lines let me just take a look here oh
boy
seems like there's a lot of pent-up
demand for people to call in at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
twelve voicemails have been recorded
yeah until I open up the phone lines it
will just go to our voicemail number and
a lot of people are calling in but the
phone lines are not yet open the phone
lines will open if we get three more new
members or patrons take your pick we end
up with about 95 96 percent of both -
the the payment fees that basically are
are taken out of that a three more and
we'll open up those phone lines
Savannah Lambert says with a nine dollar
ninety nine cent super chat thank you
for saving me from disgusts like Ben
Shapiro well I'll take any praise I can
get I don't know exactly I don't know
how I've saved anyone from Ben Shapiro
but any praise I will take particularly
with $9.99 attached to it right black
way 54 with a super chat you're it's the
POC minh scabbard abby dabba Dabba and
uh shouts to you squad black wave thank
you I literally could not have said it
better myself and I love the support
thank you okay a couple of questions in
the regular chat about what upcoming
long-form pieces do we have we have two
right now we're going to we've got a
long-form piece on the Iraqi dinar scam
this is a currency scam currency
exchange scam that is particularly
popular among trumpets and we've got a
long-form piece about that the Iraqi
dinar scam maybe next week hopefully we
also have a long-form piece on
conspiratorial thinking and that one is
actually it's a crossover episode former
TV director and my brother NAT on Pakman
has his own YouTube channel now which he
is starting up started a few months ago
it's a slowly building very sort of slow
but you could help speed that up it's
called Natanz notes Natanz notes
we're doing a crossover long-form peace
with Natanz notes where it will be the
same style and format long-form piece of
the ones we've done on our channel for
several years
it'll be roughly the same duration it
will be edited in a similar way by
producer Noah Ferguson the difference is
that instead of I instead of my voice as
the voice over it will be 'not on Pakman
voicing it over it will appear on Natanz
notes it will appear on the David Pakman
show and that I'm hoping we can get put
together by the following week or maybe
the week after it's sort of a big
undertaking because we want to do it
right okay let's see here
comments that there are Russians in the
chat yeah probably
something about people wanting to do for
me to open the phone lines I will as
soon as we get three more three more
members or patrons that's all it'll take
and you can get a yearly membership
you're not going to pay $60 you're not
gonna pay fifty five or even fifty I
sound like Ron Popeil you're not gonna
pay forty five or even forty dollars
using the coupon code 2019 you can get a
$60 membership for the low yearly price
of $20.19 okay let me get to a couple of
other super chats d.smith 551 cent a
$2.00 super chat just saying poop sounds
like that was worth about $2 yeah that
seems about right a lot of people
pointing out that there are too many
Jewish conspiracies in the chat I tend
to agree with you people talking about
Alex Jones people saying that the david
pakman show is nothing like pac-man the
video game I then tend to believe that
that's absolutely true
people checking in from Canada people
checking in from Belgium I just love
belt Belgium is one of my favorite
places it really is and when I tell
people who have traveled sort of
extensively but I've never been to
Belgium that Belgium is just one of one
of the the places I liked visiting the
most a lot of people seem confused and I
don't know why and the way I describe it
and I hope I'm not being offensive
to anyone when I say this because I love
the Netherlands and I love Brandt's
Belgium to me was a great mixing of the
more kind of laid-back French
Mediterranean culture with the
well-organized Dutch culture so that you
had kind of a French type place this is
Brussels anyway which is which is truly
you know sort of a French and Dutch
place other regions or more one than the
other Brussels is it's the city that
feels somewhat Mediterranean but also
has that great Dutch organization so
things work things are happening on time
and it's it's well organized I loved it
I loved it so hi to everyone checking in
from Belgium
Nick Kano with two Australian dollar
super chat David Pakman is my brand of
the left kudos appreciate that Nick
exercise machina with a $5 super chat in
regard to citizens united should there
be a limit to how much you can advise
others who to vote for should your
message be limited in any way I don't
know exactly what you mean like are you
saying so like the david pakman show can
only have so much influence in terms of
telling people who to vote for I I don't
I think I'm seeing these as two separate
things I think that you can have equal
time laws for example when it comes to
interviewing of candidates and
separately limit financial contributions
I think these are overlapping but
separate issues Jo Raider with a
five-dollar super chat progressive metal
band Dream Theater rocks metropolis part
one is my jam Thank You Reba P with the
$25 super chat the biggest super chat of
the evening Thank You Reba
hey David did Trump get stumped yet haha
I don't know exactly what you mean
but I really appreciate you setting the
new high-water mark for super chats for
the evening
Jacob Ball asks what do you make of
Trump canceling Pelosi strip spoke about
it at the top of the stream Jacob she
had already cancelled it according to
reports do you think it's out of
pettiness the fact that the trip was
NATO related or something else oh
definitely pettiness I think it's just
um repercussions as Trump sees it for
suppose the uninviting him from the
State of the Union address
Scott Braun with a dollar ninety-nine
thank you keep up the great content
thank you Scott
okay I think it's time to open the phone
lines page oh no it's not I'm one short
page McDonald has signed up for a
membership and Simon Wilson has signed
up for a membership we are at nine new
members and patrons during the stream
the goal was ten okay the number if we
are so lucky to get there will be six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty but we're not there yet we do need
one more new supporter before I open up
the open up the phone lines deejay truth
209 sends a super chat wanting me to
turn off the donations sound yeah that
is a little bit it's it's starting to
get a little bit oppressive let me see
if I can do that well we well we stand
by here to open up the phone lines is
that I mean I could also turn it down
but maybe people are just finding it
annoying it's like a cash register
ringing though you know there's
something to it that I like where do you
know I actually think that I can only do
it between streams I'm not sure that I
can actually turn that off right now ah
is that even the alert box or is that
the event list I don't know what I don't
know what the hell is going on here hmm
sound where is sound I see font size I
see animation but I am not seeing sound
here maybe it wasn't that one yeah I'm
gonna have to look at that more I agree
it's getting a little bit oppressive is
it over here moderation yeah I don't
know I think we're just gonna have to
deal with it for the rest of the stream
I can turn it down a little bit for now
but then I'll have to turn it back up if
and when we get to calls which we may
not because we're still stuck at nine
new members we're looking for ten
Stephen a Park Trump and Lindsey Graham
are gay lovers extraordinarily
insightful political analysis the
and hope that was worth two dollars for
you Donald J Trump has entered super
chat why won't you give me credit for
this economy make America great again
2020 okay on that note I am going to
open the phone lines because we did get
a tenth a new member samarth ragin has
made a hundred and $20 a year membership
samarth thank you not taking advantage
of the coupon code 2019 not taking
advantage of the lowest yearly rate of
$60 a year but going above and beyond
with a hundred and twenty dollar a year
membership thank you I really do
appreciate that
okay people can start calling in at six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty if they want the phone lines have
been opened and I will very very shortly
start taking phone calls let's see here
first I've got to get hooked up with the
system looking forward to hearing from
people system is like on a 30-second
delay I was we did somebody see that cat
image in the lower of what was that I've
not seen that before that was very very
strange there was like a cat and a cat
animation that showed up on screen I
don't even know where that's coming from
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty and by the way I also want
to thank there's a few other new members
Elizabeth Edwards and Jenny Walker and
Ian Venegas Venegas is a common
Argentinian last name if you are
Argentinian you're like me that's cool I
don't know I was I was hoping to go
somewhere with that but I don't know
where else to go okay let's now let's
see how I can do this we will see if I
can do this the right way I'd like to
put a couple of things up on screen here
I was just going to pull up the david
pakman show subreddit just to see what
we have going on there and I will take
phone calls as well okay so let's see
let's get that switched over so we've
got that going and then now we'll take
some phone calls
let's see who's there from the five six
one
code caller from five six one what's
going on all right this is Brian from
Florida hey Brian I had a quick question
that's been on my mind do you think that
presidential term limits actually favor
a more one of the male centrist
establishment type bias because they
were created to FDR out of the office
and they also would effectively
eventually remove Donald Trump on one
fringe and Bernie Sanders on the other
fringe so your question is are they I'm
not sure I understand that they would
effectively remove some people who
happen to be male but you're saying if
term limits are anti male is that the
question or whether they reinforce
having men in office no sorry wasn't
gender related I was wondering if they
enforce a centrist bias Oh centrist I
thought you said gender I'm sorry no I
don't think so necessarily I think if
anything they would maybe allow for a
move to the left in some ways because
they would eliminate these sort of
corporate well-funded centrists from
just kind of camping out and continuing
to raise funds and remaining in office I
don't I don't know that I agree with you
on that one that's cool you know my only
thought process was you know suppose you
consider maybe Hillary Clinton Obama to
be pretty much the same policy wise
roughly very simple but if you were to
get someone that's a little bit more
difficult to elect like Bernie Sanders
and it's just going to shut him out
eventually and yeah but I take your
point well but we already have to Bernie
Sanders gets elected president we
already you're saying you're not talking
about you're talking about removing
presidential term limits not adding them
for senators right oh no I'm in favor of
them for Congress you are okay all right
very very interesting we will continue
to research and see where that takes us
let's go to a caller who is calling in
via Skype Skype caller are you there
Skype caller are we muted or something I
don't know your there's one caller from
Skype and that's who's on right now hmm
all right well yes they got a little
little fact let's go to the 7 1 8 area
code caller from 7 1 8 go ahead
oh yes David can you hear me yeah we can
hear you fine
hi you know I'm just calling out just
during the stream but I had a question I
was just wondering how come I've been
watching you for a little while since
2016 I'm just wondering um why it
doesn't seem like you're that critical
of Russia Gator trip Russia you seem to
be very convinced and there hasn't been
really like obviously Bowlers
investigation isn't over but there
hasn't been any like you know and you
know it's innocent till proven guilty
essentially right so I'm just saying
like why don't you have some people on
like Aaron Mateo or build any these type
of people that have a lot of knowledge
of Russia Gate their crib you know the
critical of Russia gate like Glenn
Greenwald as well why do I have them on
your show and just have a discussion
with them because I feel like it's good
to be critical of the intelligence
agencies because they did liason to you
know 9/11 and I think it's it's
important to hold it can we can we
explore this like a step at a time maybe
just cuz there's a lot of a lot in there
I know who Glenn Greenwald is I have had
him on the program although it's been a
while the other people you mentioned I
don't know who they are you said that
that we should be skeptical of trusting
the intelligence agencies did you say
because they lied about 9/11 is that
what you said well what I mean is they
they essentially what they had their own
reasons for getting it into Iraq they
had their you know reasons that it
wasn't and it was very disingenuous
reason you're talking about a Bush
administration right like so we're
talking about like a couple doubles so
first let me see if I can just break it
hold on hold on okay we have time let's
see if we can bring it down
I don't know if that's a toilet flushing
or where you're taking the phone call
but let me see if we can turn that down
a little bit so we can understand each
other so I'm outside first you said that
that our intelligence agencies lied to
us about 9/11 is that do you stand by
that or do you mean that the case that
the trumpet that the Bush administration
made for Iraq was based on quality
intelligence which which of the two did
it I essentially mean there was based on
faulty intelligence I don't know if we
saw the the you know the meeting where
Robert Fuller Oh on TV and admitted and
said that there were WMDs that were in
Iraq we literally lied on the TV I
didn't see no I mean certainly there's
there's no question that the Bush
administration decided to take week and
trumped-up intelligence and have every
you know Rumsfeld and : Powell and condi
rice and Cheney and the whole slate of
them justify a war in Iraq despite Iraq
not having had anything to do with 9/11
so it sounds like on that part we sort
of are on the same page right yes good
so when now now when it comes to the
Russia investigation what have I said
that you believe is inaccurate or what
have I asserted that is untrue well I
would say that you keep referencing
these from our meeting okay there's
nothing conclusive about that
speculation about which part is spent
you hold on a second which part is spec
so let's take a break let's let's really
drill down are you saying that it's
still not proven that the meeting
happened or do you agree that it
happened no I do you hold on let's just
walk through it so we'll get to our
point of disagreement don't don't jump
ahead do you agree that individuals
associated with the Trump campaign
including Paul Manafort and Jared
Kushner and Don jr. were at the meeting
I good do you agree that a Russian
lawyer named Natalia vessel met skya who
has now been indicted for her connection
- the Kremlin was at the meeting I agree
that she was yeah she was at the meeting
as well and do you believe that the
point of the meeting as has now been
admitted even by people on the Trump
side was the premise was to provide dirt
on Hillary to help Trump defeat Hillary
do you agree with that part I would say
that that that part I would I will I
would say that it's not 100 I would 100%
agree with that okay so who is arguing
that that wasn't the case because you
have people on both sides I mean even
the Trump side now is saying the meeting
was under the pretense of getting dirt
on Hillary they're denying that they got
it but that they're even admitting that
so who can you cite who says that the
meeting was not to get dirt on Hillary
well I would say that yes obviously
opposition research is you know
something that people do know but that's
not an answer what I was saying was you
said you're not sure if you believe that
the point of the meeting was to get dirt
on Hillary and I said at this point
everyone has admitted that there's just
a disagreement as to whether they got
the dirt so can you cite anyone who is
still denying that that's what the
meeting was for no I can't find anyone
that did that okay so your your initial
premise and bringing up the Trump Tower
meeting was that I'm saying things that
haven't been proven what have I said
that hasn't been proven because so far
you've agreed with me on every point
well what I'm saying is that that that
Trump's our meeting isn't it it's like
it's being cited or some like major
thing that's going to lead to some sort
of an indictment on Donald Trump and did
I say did I say Trump was going to get
indicted because of the Trump Tower
meeting you basically insinuated that
that that particular thing is going to
somehow lead him down the path of being
impeached down the road so now so now
you're saying that I said Donald Trump
will get indicted because of the Trump
Tower meeting you're saying I said that
is it I want to understand no I'm not
saying that you
we said that I'm saying that you I in
directly indirectly said listen you're
insinuating it I I think that we've kind
of gone far enough and I think the the
audience sort of gets it I think next
time you got to be more prepared to
actually accuse me of having done
something I did and not end up agreeing
with me on every single point okay let
me get to some other people let's go to
the four one nine area code caller from
four one nine go ahead hey David
my name is Ron I'm calling from Ohio I'm
a big fan of the show I'm a big Bernie
supporter but the one issue that I'm
skeptical of is free college tuition and
there's many reasons why I'm skeptical
of it but my main concerns that I think
having free college tuition might
devalue the worth of a college degree I
think it might lead to a flood of
college graduates that have sort of
medial confusions and they're all
competing for a limited number of jobs
and I'm just curious if from how you
would count about well okay so let's
this is an interesting this is an
interesting idea so from a mere supply
and demand standpoint right if everybody
has a college degree having a college
degree is less unique and therefore it
would stand to reason that it would be
less valuable to have that degree is
that sort of the gist of what you're
saying yeah okay
I think that what you that's your right
in a sense I think that what we have to
balance that with is the reality that
just because tuition becomes free to
state universities remember it's it's a
very specific and more narrow proposal
than than just everybody gets to go to
any college for free just because you
can go to ition free to state
universities if you can get accepted
doesn't mean that everybody's going to
necessarily get accepted right so when
you look at Community College Community
College has always been to my knowledge
you just sign up and go right there's
not you have to apply and see if you can
get in so that wouldn't change yes it's
true now you could have tuition paid for
so that would make it so
more people want to go but it's always
been you can just sign up and go with
other four-year colleges and
universities even if it was tuition free
if you got in it wouldn't be guaranteed
that just because you apply you get in
and in fact if more people are applying
the acceptance rates might even go down
so I think that you're right in your
analysis merely on price if you make the
price zero or close to zero you will
have a lot more people who are now
interested but there's a whole bunch of
other reasons why it's not necessarily
going to lead to this deluge in all
sorts of people ending up with degrees
then and not to mention that if you're
not suited for college and not everybody
is even if you do get in begin you
choose to apply because it's free
tuition that's not a guarantee that
you're gonna end up with the degree
either you've still got to make it
through you know what I mean of course
yeah and you know that all sounds pretty
sound to me I guess you know I'd have to
probably research some of the numbers of
people who graduate or people that
enroll and you know but don't know
interesting responses about that all
right yeah thank you for their call good
good question I appreciate it let me
mention a couple other super chats
before I take a couple more phone calls
Simon Wilson says greetings from the UK
where it is 12:15 in the morning now
12:30 Thank You Simon for staying up
late
Reba P sends a follow-up super chat Wow
Donald J Trump can't not only talk he
can't spell tisk tisk smoo in laughter
Reba I'm having trouble tonight
understanding some of your messages but
I appreciate the support mister toxic
butterfly can I send you fan art for the
Pat cave yeah I don't know if I mean it
could maybe be put in the Pat cave not
in view of the cameras but I can't
commit to putting up you could send
anything I don't know what you're gonna
send random rapper says g'day from
Australia mate you're oh you always seem
so chilled out it's great thank you love
your shows appreciate it thank you very
much
okay let's go to the eight one seven
area code caller from eight one seven
what's going on hey what's going on this
is Frank Penney farofa
I'm a pre I'm one of those 300 guys that
a 300 plus that became a new
member so you talked about this thing
before okay but I'm just a quick
question I'm wondering about your own
credentials you were just talking about
college education you seem like a really
educated guy I didn't know if you're
just a self-starter or if you've got any
credentials yourself I actually did not
get past sixth grade incredibly are you
serious isn't that insane
yeah that's pretty insane but that's
also I mean I'm glad that you're someone
that I'm an I'm an educator I just got
my masters in education I'm starting my
career right now so the fact that I can
have someone to point to and say hey you
know you can still succeed even if you
didn't get through sixth grade no I'm
just kidding I'm just having a good time
I actually I don't know man I mean I'm
kidding around your reaction was so
authentic please clip that someone clip
that out of this live stream and we got
it we have to use that on social media
no I I have a under drive a bachelor's
degree in economics and communication
and I have a I have an MBA as well in
financial planning and economics okay
fantastic that'll make sense and I
figured you probably had done some
reading at some point you were you
probably had learned some stuff but I
was just curious thank you very much I
appreciate the call and thank you for
you by the way can you talk about how
membership is just the best thing ever
yeah it's fantastic I've been listening
to your podcast every day since I have
had access to them watch the videos when
I get the chance but a lot times I'm on
the road and so commuting yeah it's
great to have the the excerpt the bonus
show is what you call it and and all the
extra content fantastic so I appreciate
what you do I'm enjoying it appreciate
it and I'll send you that check I
mentioned if you would call in and say
this after I get off that would be great
alright big have a good night thanks yep
have a good one and speaking of
membership let me say thank you to
Abigail Muniz also Chris Jones and okay
I think that's it and oh and Jerri
Hickel Jerri Hickel as well let's go to
the five seven one area code caller from
five seven one go ahead
hey what's up David in my own you're on
right now
beautiful um hey I I'm watching you from
a about a year see fan I like what you
do I had two questions ready I don't
want you a ton so I'm just gonna see
which one you have an
yes okay um do you think that the way to
beat Trump is to either have a very
progressive Democratic candidate or to
have a more centrist Democrat so it's a
fair question I think it's the wrong one
only in the sense that I think that
that's sort of an electability game and
I'm doing everything I can to stay away
from these electability games because
when it comes down to it half the
country doesn't vote okay so you can win
with a centrist candidate and you can
win with a more progressive candidate if
the left gets out and votes as an
individual I'm more progressive so I
would rather a more progressive
candidate but I would not have
particular evidence to support this is
we're in uncharted territory everything
that's going on is totally whacked and
and we've not had a reelection campaign
for a president who has done the things
that Donald Trump has done so I I think
that you can make an electability case
one way or the other I would have a
personal preference for the progressive
but ultimately you can win with either
if you get the turnout out what people
what do you say who do you think has a
better chance though I mean you know
Sanders had a lot of support obviously
Clinton took it Clinton had more votes
she's not really centrist so that one
might argue that's the way to go you
know on the other side if you want to
pull some Trump supporters the way you
might want someone down the middle so
yeah I just am one sure that that's the
type of calculation where the left ends
up losing like okay I can start kind of
Democrats that might pull Trump
supporters away but also Trump
supporters are suffering from such
cognitive dissonance that I don't know
that for their own sanity they would
necessarily be willing to be pulled away
so I just I think it's the wrong game to
play and I'm going to evaluate it as
who's currently running who's closest to
my politics right now it's Elizabeth
Warren
I'm not making any electability
assessment I'm just saying right from
the people right now I believe Elizabeth
Warren is most in line with my politics
yeah that's fair cool do you have time
for one more from me Laurie gets it call
back again I've got so many people
holding I want to get to people who are
who are there because I have unlimited
I've limited time thank you for the call
really appreciate it
let's go back to that caller who is
calling from Skype and see if we if we
can get them on skype caller are you
there yeah think I'm gonna have to bail
on the Skype calls because I'm guessing
they can hear me and that's why they
called back but we can't hear them let's
go to the three six one area code caller
from three six one what's going on oh
let me that is hey David uh thanks for
answering uh I said a question about the
UH I know you can't jump a lot on his
tariffs because you know they are his
policy on trade is not working but I was
just a little bit curious you turned out
a little bit but let me to elaborate
more on what you think the ideal trade
policy is regarding NAFTA and trade in
general okay so here's here's the issue
right now you have a lot of sort of um
absolutists who like to say free trades
been a neoliberal disaster okay
fair or people who like to say when we I
support free trade but I mean actual
free trade meaning real free trade not
sort of free trade with agreements and
limitations and all of this other stuff
the problem with a lot of the arguments
on trade is they sort of assume that
we're starting from a blank slate and
they say if we were to if the United
States was a new country and we were
entering relationships with other
countries from scratch here's the ideal
system and the problem is that that's
just not how things are working so for
example there are people who say no you
know David I I'm I think that the
tariffs will create some pain in the
short-term but it's the right thing to
do to China because of all this stuff
that China has done to us which we
should be trying to stop okay fine
maybe you take that position what's the
off-ramp from these tariffs because
given that we're not starting from a
blank slate we're not starting from zero
we're talking about the marginal effect
of these policies we're not talking
about if you had no policy and you drop
a policy in what would happen and how
how would it work we're talking about
we're starting from where we were when
Trump became president and we have to
think of the marginal impact of the
policies as I was reading today
number one we were told that the Trump
tariff policy would reduce the trade
deficit with China the trade deficit
grew to its largest ever in 2018 even in
inflation-adjusted so that is backfired
by Trump's own stated goals when it
comes to who pays for the tariffs yes
the tariffs on China have generated
billions of dollars in additional
spending by American companies who are
the ones actually doing the spending and
that's not good for American companies
so I think the real problem I have is
that people are talking about trade
policy in a vacuum we're not operating
in a vacuum we have to operate in the
real world
oh that's sir yeah and you would be
dependent appoints people so I think I
can read most of that thank you okay
thanks I appreciate the call I'll take a
couple more calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go to our caller from the 765 area
code caller from 765 then I'll get to
these super chats that have been coming
in David Thomas calling from Indiana how
are you doing today good how are you
good thanks for taking my call I think
you're a great voice for the progressive
media I think you do a good job thank
you a question I won't want to want to
talk to you about is I know you talked a
lot about finances and the economy flat
tax but do you think are you do you look
at flat tax as appropriate or do you
think we are taxed enough and that we
just need to allocate our money better
because with so much money like there's
you know the tax system better than I do
yeah but corporate taxes and corporate
taxes and then state taxes income taxes
all that if it was just all wiped away
and it was made of flat tax and we just
allocated our money better do you think
that could bolster communities and you
know everything from education to
infrastructure does that could health
care come from that what are your
opinions yeah so I'm against the flat
tax I do believe in a progressive tax
system so and I could dig into that and
we have so
flat-tax I don't see the flat tax as the
alternative to all of these other taxes
that we have now when it comes to tax
rates I believe in a progressive tax a
progressive tax bracket system but I am
not the type of progressive who is all
about sort of punishing people for
success that's not my approach my
approach is we live in a society we are
no longer in a state of nature and
Taxation is is a necessity period okay
given that taxation is a necessity there
are some sort of basic phenomena that we
can identify about how money works one
of those is that if you have a lot of
money a little bit of additional money
is not as nearly as useful to you as a
little bit of additional money is to
someone who doesn't have a lot of money
right so if you have ten million dollars
an extra thousand bucks doesn't do as
much for you it has a smaller marginal
utility than if you have ten thousand
bucks and someone gives you a thousand
dollars so where I think taxation taxes
should be set are at a point where
number one entrepreneurs and business
people and those who invest a lot of
time and money in education to then have
a job that earns a salary that they're
happy with for example that people can
enjoy the fruits of that but that over
time as they make more and more money
and achieve success that is more and
more out of sync with sort of like the
median income that more and more of that
earnings more and more of those earnings
of that money to speak grammatically
correctly is used for the greater good
so do where exactly do tax rates need to
be I don't know I'm kind of flexible on
that but there's no question to me that
number one I am for people keeping as
much of the money they make as is
reasonable as long as it allows us to
live in a society that makes sense and I
do think that to your point about how
money is spent we could do so much more
with the tax rates that we already have
if we were spending less on defense and
the military-industrial complex complex
and the military and all of that stuff
so all of the above except I'm not in
favor of a flat tax
I appreciate your answer I do want to
say this I think Trump gives us the
ability to have a lot of conversations
about mental health and about how you
know there's an age gap difference and
just political beliefs and stuff like
that I think you're one of the few
outlets out there that does a good job
digging into some of that
thank you a huge fan of your debunked
series that you had gone but I I'm
actually I'm actually I'm actually
joining the military I shift next
Tuesday so I wanted to call in and tell
you to keep doing what you're doing
Wow I'm a fan and I hope you continue on
continued strong and just keep doing
what you're doing then and what what now
in 2019 has has catalyzed you to say I'm
now going to join the military this this
isn't a political move by me this is a
personal decision for me and my family
I'm going into the healthcare field so
I'm gonna use the military to get my
education to buy my mom a house and to
better myself and it gives me the
ability to do that and that's that's
that's my decision it has nothing to do
with politics I want to stay away from
that understand it's the conservative
you know branch that I'm entering but I
think it's worth the fight and you know
it's it's worth having the entire
conversation so I just wanted to call in
and touch base with you man you do a
good job okay all right thank you
appreciate the call best of luck let me
do a couple other super chats exercise
machina says how how is it progressive
to give rich kids free college yeah
that's the wrong approach okay so the
two things on that number one the means
testing of these programs often ends up
costing more than the savings of saying
the rich kids don't get free tuition but
more importantly the programs for free
tuition are programs for state colleges
and universities Oh
those rich kids are going to private
schools so it's not I think that that's
that's the wrong approach I'm not
worried about that you're always going
to have some Free Riders people who
don't really need a benefit who get it
but get rid of means-testing bureaucracy
and realize that it's for the greater
good for sure
Robert Salazar says if someone steals my
Pat fan art and tries to pass it as
their own I'm gonna flip okay well I'll
keep an eye on that for sure
Annabelle the Paladin says any advice
for job searching I've been to job
searching websites they all seem to send
you in circles without letting you fill
out applications Annabelle here is
something I learned early enough that I
want to tell you I don't know how old
you are I want to tell everybody who may
at some point be looking for a job the
worst way to get a job is to start
filling out applications on job sites
and what I mean by that is not that jobs
aren't given out that way are made that
way but this is sort of one of those
things where we can say it's good or bad
but it just is networking your way to a
job is the best path forward if you can
use your time if you're really executing
a full-time job search only spend some
of the time filling out applications
online spend a lot of the time
contacting influencers in your community
finding shared interests and going to
get a cup of coffee with them and
mentioning that you're in the middle of
a job search if you're in a position to
work with a recruiter who you don't have
to pay and would earn money from getting
you a job look at getting other people
working to get you jobs use the networks
that you have go to networking events
depending on your age find a Chamber of
Commerce or a young professionals event
or something through a community group
or whatever I I would be spending
probably two-thirds of my time and what
the hell do I know I haven't applied for
a job in ten years at this point but
from I'm involved in a lot of this stuff
from a sort of mentorship capacity I
would to be spending two thirds of my
time networking and one third of my time
looking for jobs online and and filling
out applications that's my advice it's
worth I guess I guess it's worth about
the five bucks that you sent on the
super Chad not but not more not less
Clavell offeri Hill says in Germany
there was nearly no media coverage about
the canceled Davos trip but a lot about
the government shutdown seems like the
European leaders in the media are
relieved to meet without the chaos yeah
I've pointed this out before it's kind
of a it's kind of a bummer but
increasingly the u.s. is just not a
necessary player and a lot of the
important conversations that are being
had certainly not conversations about
climate change because you've got a
climate denier in the White House who's
pulling us out of the Paris climate
Accord so it's it's you're exactly right
leaders are just saying it's kind of
better without Trump here okay let me
take just a couple more calls we'll go
to the five-seven one area code caller
from 571 what's going on hey how's it
going
good good okay so the second question I
was actually wondering do you think well
before with the two questions and now
you called back oh yeah told me to okay
I didn't mean today but you listen
you're you're on you can cut me off like
I'm gonna take the second question go
ahead okay um I'm wondering if you think
that in terms of protest do you think
that peaceful protest is effective or do
people have to become you know kind of
borderline violent to - you know invoke
changes from from Washington okay good
question there's a lot of intermediate
steps between peaceful protests and what
we would call sort of violent protests
I've mentioned a lot of those things
before forms of civil disobedience
strategic defaults mass rallies in urban
centers we actually did a segment a
couple of weeks ago called something
like types of activism that will get
results quick there are ways to non
violently [ __ ] the systems that the
elites and those in power depend on
which are beyond just what we would call
signing a petition or calling your
elected official they are more than that
but they are not violent and I think
that that those are steps that are often
unknown to a lot of people and there's
this false notion that it's either
totally peaceful in every way or
starting to get violent there's a lot of
these actions that we could call may be
systemic ly violent economically violent
but not physical violence of
any kind not criminal in any kind of
great sense which I would encourage more
people to learn about yeah
well that's great I'm I guess like some
of the events that have um you know
stuck in the history of books are like
what uh was Rodney I guess the the LA
event with the Rodney King ride captured
yes right so things like that when
people get violent I really captured and
I think they send the big waves but you
need to make some good points sorry to
flood your line on my name is Colin and
yeah next time I'll call you a different
day okay appreciate the call thank you
so much on that note it is time for me
to wrap I'm making dinner tonight and
we've gotten to the end of the time but
I really want to thank everybody I also
there's a couple other people Stephen
Johnson became a member and who's this
Avery McDonald also I want to thank for
signing up for a membership thanks to
everybody the support in January has
just been unbelievable
and I'll have more news for you soon
about what we've got cooking for
February hint February is my birthday
month so we we bought we're obviously
doing something thanks to everybody I'll
do another stream soon